time president trump is threatening to  take the state of nevada to court over  plans to hold a mail-in election this  fall  that after nevada lawmakers passed a  bill during the special session this  weekend  active voters would get their ballots by  mail for the 2020 election  president trump of course has been an  outward opponent of mainland voting  because he believes it could lead to  voter fraud and here's what he tweeted  out earlier this morning  it says quote in an illegal late night  coup nevada's clubhouse governor made it  impossible for republicans to win the  state  post office could never handle the  traffic of mail and votes without  preparation  using cova to steal the state see you in  court  so that bill will now head to the  governor's desk governor syslaxdesk  and he is expected to sign it sometime  today so we'll follow that for you